the symbol for the higgs boson is sadly
the most boring thing in the world it's
a lowercase letter h
it is it depends you know different
there's no agreed upon symbol i think
that lowercase h is the most common but
uppercase h is used uppercase phi or
lowercase phi or various other things
are sometimes used the higgs boson is a
tiny little vibration
in a field called the higgs field just
as the photon the particle of light is a
tiny vibration in the electromagnetic
field for example the higgs boson is not
important the higgs boson is a little
bit of a red herring what matters what
is crucial for the operation of physics
is the higgs field that pervades all of
space and the reason why we spent so
much effort looking for the higgs boson
is because it's evidence that there is
something called the higgs field it's a
vibration in this field that we've been
looking for for over 40 years now
is the higgs boson
the only way to find the higgs field
well it's the direct way so when steven
weinberg and salaam put together what we
call the electro weak theory when they
unified
electromagnetism with a weak nuclear
force they assumed that the universe was
full of this thing called the higgs
field and that played a crucial role in
making sense of of the rest of the
physics that followed
and that theory made predictions and it
fit a lot of data and the predictions
came true nobel prizes were given to
glacial weinberg salaam to a tuft and
velman for figuring out the mathematical
underpinnings of the theory for the
experimenters carlo rubia and simon
vandermeer for finding the w and z
bosons that were predicted
but it was relying on this ingredient
the higgs field that had never been
directly detected the lhc is an amazing
amazing piece of equipment i mean i
wrote this book about the search for the
higgs and i came to it as a theoretical
cosmologist i was already very very
impressed with the experimenters before
i started writing the book but i'm much
more impressed now having done it the
largest machine ever built
thousands of people working on it 27
kilometers around thousands of
superconducting magnets colder than
interstellar space a vacuum inside the
beam pipe that is emptier than the
atmosphere of the moon and they're
colliding uh particles together protons
together at incredibly high energies and
just watching what comes out
and the amazing single most amazing fact
to me about the lhc is that when you
collide protons together
we have such a wonderful understanding
of particle physics that almost
everything that comes out is exactly
what you would expect
so what they do is they just over
produce data you know they have a
hundred million collisions per second
very very roughly the problem with that
is that every collision is a megabyte of
data and there's no possible way you can
store all that information
so for every million events that they
produce they store one of them to tape
they very quickly look at the event say
is this possibly interesting oh no they
throw it away or yes and they will keep
it so this idea of filtering and
throwing away almost all the data
turns out to be necessary because what
you're looking for is you know the one
in a hundred billion event uh you can't
do it just by creating less data and
keeping it all right you really need to
go through this elaborate process and
miraculously you know there was one
thing we thought that was absolutely
going to be found at the lhc and we
found it and that's the higgs boson
we're still looking for things beyond
that of course but what is it about what
the large hadron collider does that
produces that one in a billion event
well if you believe as i do that we
should think about particle physics in
terms of fields what's really happening
is that the inner workings of the
protons are quarks and gluons so there's
vibrating quark fields and vibrating
gluon fields and they smack together and
create a very elaborate high amplitude
vibration so it's much like if you're
playing the piano very loudly in one
room and there's another piano sitting
in the room next to you it will begin to
hum along in residence with your sound
waves so these gluons and quarks start
vibrating and they start the other
fields of particle physics to vibrating
because all the fields are coupled to
each other in very subtle ways so gluons
start vibrating and then top quarks
start vibrating and ultimately a higgs
vibration is brought into existence and
it decays almost instantly in about one
zeptosecond so you will never see the
higgs boson in any experiment ever done
it instantly turns into other things and
then the hard work begins because you
need to pick out the higgs events the
the collisions where higgs boson was
produced by looking at all of the
different events you got and say well
there's more of this type of event than
we would have expected so you do a
little bit of detective work and say the
only way that could be true is if
there's a higgs when these huge
collisions happen with all this energy
and all these fields start wiggling why
is the higgs field so reluctant to join
the party
there's there's two reasons uh the most
simple reason is that it's heavy
a heavy field is one that has a lot of
mass and as we all know e equals m c
squared so energy of a particle just
sitting there is the mass times the
speed of light squared so creating a
particle with a lot of mass
means you need to take a lot of energy
and put it into a very very small region
of space that's why you need this
elaborate nine billion dollar particle
accelerator just to make a few tiny
higgs bosons and the other thing besides
the energy that it takes is how it
couples how it interacts with other
fields the top cork for example is a
little bit heavier than the higgs boson
but it's a little bit easier to make
because it interacts more directly with
other fields that we know about so in
particle physics you just can
characterize everything you're looking
for by how heavy it is and how it
interacts how you can make it and the
higgs was right there where the lhc
could finally find it higgs bosons do
form very very very rarely but it does
happen because you have to remember
everything that the large hadron
collider does the universe does all the
time and better there are cosmic rays
that are impacting the earth's
atmosphere with much higher energies
than we can produce at the lhc
but they're up high in the earth's
atmosphere then the higgs boson decays
one zeptosecond later so it's kind of
impractical to search for new exotic
particles that way
but definitely yeah higgs fields are
vibrating throughout the universe there
is the the non-vibrating field you know
the background and that is crucially
important to all of particle physics
electrons and quarks and so forth move
through this higgs-like molasses or i
should say molasses like higgs and
that's how they get mass that's what
makes the universe interesting you know
there's only a small number of
fundamental ingredients of reality i
mean in fact you could bring it down you
could boil it down to four if you wanted
to there's gravity
there are the other forces of nature all
of which sort of have the same kind of
basic structure
there is the matter particles that make
up your atoms you know the the up and
down quarks and your protons and
neutrons the electrons in your atoms and
then there's the higgs
right so it's one of a very very tiny
number of fundamental ingredients you
need to explain the world around you how
much is it worth finding that and
verifying that it's there
the only accurate answer is that it's
priceless right you know it depends on
how much money you have to spend on
basic research because you're not trying
to cure cancer with this you're not
trying to fly to mars or anything like
that
we're not going to get jet packs it's
not going to make a better iphone
but it helps us understand how the world
works i mean it's a feature of doing
this kind of research that you always do
get technological spin-offs the world
wide web was a spin-off of research at
cern but that's not why we do it we do
it because we want to understand things
and fortunately we still have enough
money to do it
i guess i mean i'm not asking for a jet
pack or even a cure to cancer but has
this unlocked a new level has this
unlocked
if for you guys
has it unlocked a new level or is it
just is it the is it the you are right
well done pat on the back no we're
certainly very hopeful that it is not
only a capstone achievement but a window
onto a whole new world one of the nice
things about the higgs boson is that
it's a little bit more sociable than
other kinds of particles and we know
there are particles we haven't yet
detected we know there's dark matter in
the universe if it weren't for dark
matter and dark energy we might really
be worried
that the particles we already knew about
were all that were accessible to us but
we know that's not true
most of the of the mass in our galaxy is
not made of the particles that we've
created here on earth so we're hopeful
that by studying the higgs boson this
gives us a new way of looking for other
particles the ways that the higgs boson
is produced the way it decays the way it
use it becomes a force mediating
interactions between dark matter
particles and other particles these are
all new toys for particle physics to
study and play with this is going to be
going on for 20 30 40 years into the
future these are some incredibly
talented hard-working dedicated bright
human beings
the theorists the technicians and the
experimenters who
built the theories and built the large
hadron collider and they've devoted
their lives literally to looking for a
particle that may or may not be there
and that when you find it is not going
to make you any richer it's just going
to make you a little bit happier that
you found it uh so i wanted to get
across why this was so crucial i mean
why physicists in the united states were
crushed with disappointment when
congress in 1993 canceled the united
states's competitor to the large hadron
collider the superconducting super
collider why physicists are still a
little bit on tenterhooks about will
there ever be another particle
accelerator the scale of the lhc um you
know they devote their lives to it the
theorists might spend their entire life
working on a theory that the accelerator
then says isn't true
you know you have to learn to deal with
that but
you then get these pictures of peter
higgs and and and um francois glare and
other physicists who came up with the
idea
of the higgs boson back in 1964
and they got to be in the room in 2012
when the experimenters told them you
were right that is part of nature and
that is a kind of sweet triumphant
success that we can rarely experience as
human beings for me it's
really an incredible thing that has
happened in my lifetime as a cosmologist
who's alive at this time you're very
fortunate you got to enjoy this
announcement
you won't live forever i'm sure
does it frustrate you that those next
things those things that are
40 50 60 years away just beyond your
lifetime
you never get to see do you ever think
about that
well i think that the great thing about
science is that we almost are always
focused on what we don't yet understand
and
sometimes the new understandings come
vast and furious uh you know there are
times like the 1920s when quantum
mechanics was being put together when
it's hard to imagine what it must have
been like
when i wrote my book about the arrow of
time i delved into the work in
statistical mechanics and thermodynamics
in the 1870s and the debates there are
just fascinating to read because they
didn't know it was really fundamental
stuff and they were building it from
scratch and some people didn't believe
in atoms at all right and other people
were using atoms to explain everything
and now in particle physics we've put
the capstone on the standard model and
we're hoping to find dark matter and
cosmology we found dark matter and dark
energy
i can't say over the next 10 years 50
years are we going to be
strewn with new shocking experimental
results or are we just going to be you
know fine-tuning the understanding we
already have i think the fact that we
don't know which of those is going to
happen is part of what actually makes it
interesting
but i think about someone like albert
einstein when he was born and i kind of
think oh gee i wish i could just tell
those guys what we found out a few weeks
ago they would have been so happy to
know about it and it'll be the same for
you when you're going like oh i wish i
could have told sean about this thing he
would have loved to know that does that
does that eat away it does it does not
actually because you could say that
about anybody right you could say you
know what would einstein have told
newton but you know newton had his own
fun right he got to invent physics
basically right i mean newton could have
told galileo things but galileo did his
own his own thing i think that every
generation gets to apply the talents it
has to the problems that it's faced with
and right now in science not just
particle physics and cosmology but
overall there's so many great problems
and so much interesting data coming in
that uh we are at no loss for
interesting questions to puzzle over
the change of the evolution of the
universe we only need one we only need
the schrodinger equation it in the
copenhagen interpretation the the thing
that we teach our students the thing
that's in the textbooks